hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the impossible game one
of the hardest games ever made and it
was recently released on Steam so I'm
just gonna get to it I'm gonna play
there is no explanation
you press a jump button to jump that's
about it and then you die because you're
horrible at life so you guys haven't
seen me play a rage game in a while so
I'm eager to feed that horrible horrible
missus deep inside your soul that wants
to see me suffer but anyway this game
was actually released like a long time
ago in its very musical game where
you're just a simple box and all you
need to do is jump over the spikes and I
played it a long time ago I did I don't
even know if there's an end to it all I
know is that it's just it it consumes
your entire life and all you need to do
is try not to die how hard could that be
god damn it I was on a streak there I
was actually surprised of my own
goodness so the funny thing about this
game is that there is no way to not go
back to the beginning unless you set a
flag and I've forgotten how to set a
flag I think it's I yeah I think it's
actually a mouse control that they need
to learn um left no left is oh yeah okay
alright hang on let me try to find
didn't read the controls I thought I
knew how to play no I'm not in practice
mode alright you know what I'm gonna get
out of here and I'm gonna go to a
different level I want to go to a
different level level do chaos fantasy
because I've actually played the first
level too many times it's old-school I
need an actual challenge I'm too good at
this game to be beaten by it
and you guys understand that the skill
level that I'm bringing to the table
here is just too incredible to be
ignored oh my god I made it ah
I may get it oh god oh I saw death
coming before me and it wanted to
destroy me oh when you're not in
practice mode you have to suffer through
the consequences of failure that the
consequence is a failure of elite severe
because it's def and I mean death is a
pretty severe consequence to anything
come on come on you coober honey goober
come on everything is a blur my eyes
breaking or things blurring along I
don't know how is it supposed to look oh
I thought I made that come on
uh-huh this is a different type of rage
game than the other ones because it's so
hard to get into it far because it's so
easy to fail at the beginning and then
you have to repeat what you thought you
knew before I did better on my first try
than I ever did here oh god oh god I'm
gonna die Oh God
my entire life is watch my eyes ah god
damn it to the music just a second okay
god damn it the music just resets to its
classic self and then I don't even have
room to think about what's coming before
because I have to suddenly reset my
brain did what's happening before and
try to remember how I got through it in
the bird blades although I am able to
sigh read this pretty well oh God
I saw failure coming by I was closing my
eyes I stood up my eyes on the game okay
let's not to get too overly dramatic
over here just remember that it's a
simple game and then I am here to splay
it and commentate on it for you guys as
you can see the art development of this
okay the art development of these spikes
here was very art Adele cake the
triangular shape of these spikes in
terms of graphical fidelity is
incredible the audio tracks is beautiful
in my ears and I can't wait to go home
and cry in a blanket because I want to
curl up in a ball and die okay I'm gonna
persevere because I am a rock this
randomizing is it Oh lovely for me I
know I don't know okay obviously it's
not random obviously in a set pattern
and I need oh okay let me try it with
the mouse Oh God
[ __ ] alright this is just gonna be a
whole lot of fun I know that I'm gonna
get able to get through this you know in
a way it's kind of reminiscent of guitar
here you just gotta put huh he's got
press a button at the same time they
usually do every time it's a set pattern
set to music that is the total in some
relation to whatever the gal get okay
whatever game I just was talking guitar
here or a rock band or whatever except
you're not playing the band you're
actually in a back alley being beaten up
by all your friends and they're taking
your lunch money and then they call you
stupid
they spit on Your Grave cuz you're dead
I guess and this is hell this is exactly
what I imagined hell would be like Oh
God not use the box not something as
exes oh come on I'm going back to the
spacebar
it's much easier then okay come on just
concentrate what was I even talking
about something about hell something
about being constantly stuck in hell
something about looping hell over and
over in your mind I did this so well the
first time why is it hard now that's
what she said oh come on this is cuz I'm
so twitchy now I'm like trying to
anticipate and remember what happened oh
god damn it
I'm very crumpled right now I don't want
anyone to talk to me I don't want to
hear anything from anyone I don't want
to do anything I just need to calmly
relax and feel it in the beat of my butt
oh yes oh yes oh good for me oh why why
would you do that that's not fair that's
just a bunch of baloney
okay whatever just Kong feel it in your
bones feel it's close to your heart okay
feeling close to your death I'm gonna
kill you ah why what would you do that
stop it trying to be nice here I'm
trying to get through this I want to
like your game I want to recommend that
people buy it just was released on Steam
a cently
taught it clay these games for your bah
bow ties don't dick with God did you
know that a square is actually two
triangles put together it doesn't matter
whole key then you know that a square is
two triangles ball kick did you know
that a square is two uh isosceles
triangles put together that's probably
not right I probably look stupid in the
geometric community huh
the trick is you gotta let go on those
and actually fall down oh wow why jump
back Nick well happy 50th attempt
everybody okay that was fun glad that
lasted I am much worse than when I
started out this game and it's not like
I'm trying not to be worse we're trying
to be gooder
I'm not
been able to memorize exactly what
happened okay one two - okay there's one
one two one lockbox two one one two one
two - that's actually helping because
I'm actually reading ahead instead of
just trying to watch them as they come
to - oh yeah oh yeah oh that's good oh
that's good
oh that's good oh that's good oh god I
did it again one one two one look 2 1 1
2 1 2 2 1 1 2 1 o'clock 1 1 2 1 gap okay
what are you getting boring for you guys
watching the same thing over and over
and me just failing over and over I love
the idea of failure it's my favorite
thing and just it's what gets me out of
bed in the morning oh come on I made it
God fingers damn it this is impossible
okay I don't even I don't I'm not even
trying to say that ironically cuz the
game with the game is e they're
impossible game but it's just stupid
you're stupid you're still gay I jumped
I am pressing the button and let my
keyboard is broken
you have no excuse for failing me I
plead I'm gonna have to take a
dominating role I'm gonna be more
aggressive Oh Bobby more passive please
if you could just baby let me through
okay that's ha she looks just like I
throw I would love to be a bit more
aggressive in it dominating in terms of
this game I love a alpha male lamb I'm
beta
I'm theta I'm a set of Zed male I'm an
Omega male which is like the worst you'd
think it'd be good but I'm bad huh come
on huh okay now we're making some
progress now we're getting somewhere now
we're cooking with gas or dead yeah oh
come on how am I not getting bad I swear
there's some lag on the input here okay
I don't know
oh okay Coleco can I let go let go here
yes
oh I was only gone no don't let me die I
just want to get through this please my
family I don't have a family really well
I mean I got my brother and my mom but I
mean that's how my like wife child the
hostage situation we please let him go
let him live for one more day oh they're
dead huh come on draw I let go of blah
Carly I want to beat you but I don't
know if there is an end to this
oh I thought it was gonna die though so
I didn't I thought that maybe I was
gonna okay I have no cheese for that I
thought I was gonna die I thought I was
gonna land into the hole just like that
as long as I think I'm gonna live and
then apparently I'm not so you just you
just sassafras you're okay do I look I
be under it everybody I just want to get
through this game I'm already sweating
boy Oh God Roger nutters okay didn't
even look up need to pay attention
because I need to get have oh come on
please please can I just plead with you
please please if you just let me win oh
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on
jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump
jump jump jump pop oh okay it's all
right oh it's okay it always physically
hurts Oh Italy okay I'm doing even worse
you may think that my eyes are closed
but I was able to see okay not to see to
relax just nice and calm think of
puppies and kittens okay I'm going to
die over and over if this personal L
mind I'm going to lose my mind
and then I'm going to fall down a bit of
Fair and by dog butter nutters through
whatever the hell his name was is gonna
join me in the afterlife and then he's
not gonna like me anymore he's gonna
stiff my head today he's gonna bite me
cuz he doesn't like me anymore liver
failure
I'm just a failure over and over again I
hate God I was gonna get through it
I'm really trying to focus here I don't
know why people would even think that I
I would know
let go why not
oh oh it physically hurts I'm in misery
I'm in agony why can't I get through the
same oh I am just wanna get through
please that thank you
please to thank you please to thank you
please to thank you god damn it oh this
stop please stop it I need to fix my
webcam cuz I hit it why can't I do this
I did it so perfectly the first time I'm
going to lose my mind
and then I'm gonna go on a this stupid
music is looping over and over in my
head and I do not care for it hey I'm
going to ha I'm gonna strangle like a
million octopus I don't know something
that's not illegal the strangle what's
what's not illegal to strangle probably
nothing living okay go God let go let go
just let go hmm
I think of crying I think I'm crying
guys I think I literally crying I don't
want to do it anymore
I don't wanna do the play I was supposed
to be a happy fun game if this is like
the first game I started recording today
come on god no oh god I thought I was
dead but I was not yes